WILL THANK YOU, ASHLEY.
IT?
>> IS.
AINSLEY: WHERE OVERCOUNTING THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN HOSPITALIZED
WITH COVID-19.
NEW DATA FINDS CALIFORNIA
OVERCOUNTED CHILD
HOSPITALIZATIONS BY AT LEAST
40%.
POTENTIALLY DISTORTING THE
NATIONAL FIGURES ON THE EFFECT
OF THE DISEASE ON OUR CHILDREN.
SO LET’S BRING IN FOX NEWS
MEDICAL CONTRIBUTOR DR. NICOLE
SAPHIER.
GOOD MORNING, DR. SAPHIER.
>> GOOD MORNING AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
THIS IS BASED ON TWO DIFFERENT
STUDIES.
HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
WHY ARE THESE NUMBERS INFLATED?
>> WELL, AINSLEY, UNDOUBTEDLY
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN HARMED AS A
MEANS OF SOME OF THE
RESTRICTIONS PUT IN PLACE TO TRY
TO KEEP THEM SAFE FROM COVID-19.
WHILE WE HAVE ACKNOWLEDGED FOR
MONTH NOW THAT THE RISK TO
CHILDREN IS EXTREMELY RARE IN
TERMS OF HOSPITALIZATION AND
DEATH.
ABOUT 77 TIMES LESS THAN THAT
FOR THOSE ADULTS AGED 65 AND
OLDER.
THIS NEW STUDY OUT OF STANFORD
MAY TELL US EVEN OUR PERCEIVED
LOW RISK OF SEVERITY IN CHILDREN
IS EVEN LIKELY LOWER THAN THAT
THIS DATA CAME OUT.
THERET THROW SPECKIVELY LOOKED
AT 265 PATIENT CHARTS OF
CHILDREN WHO ARE HOSPITALIZED
AND LISTED AS A COVID
HOSPITALIZATION.
THE DATA SHOWED ABOUT 46% OF
THOSE CHILDREN WERE LIKELY
ADMITTED TO THAT HOSPITAL WITH
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THE FACT
THAT THEY WERE POSITIVE FOR SARS
COV 2.
NOW THAT THE TESTING FOR VIRUS
WHEN THEY COME INTO THE
HOSPITAL.
THEY ARE FINDING THOSE
INFECTIONS TO BE INCIDENTAL.
40 TO 45 OF THOSE CHILDREN WERE
ASYMPTOMATIC.
THEY JUST TESTED POSITIVE FOR
THE VIRUS.
THIS JUST ADDS TO THE BODY OF
EVIDENCE THAT TELLS US THAT WHEN
CHILDREN ARE POSITIVE FOR THE
VIRUS, THEY HAVE A VERY MILD
DISEASE COURSE IF ANY SYMPTOMS
WHATSOEVER.
AND YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER,
AINSLEY, WE DEALT WITH THIS ALLY
WITH THETHIS ALITTLE BIT LAST SU
DEATH COUNTS EVEN ADULTS.
WE HAVE TO BE CAREFUL.
THERE IS A PERCEIVED RISK AND
THAT IS WHAT A LOT OF THESE
RESTRICTIONS ARE BASED UPON.
BUT IT IS PRUDENT THAT WE GET
THIS RISK RIGHT AS WE KNOW THAT
WE HAVE HARMED OUR CHILDREN AND
ADULTS WHETHER IT COMES TO A LOT
OF THESE RESTRICTIONS.
SO, THIS JUST, AGAIN, ADDS TO
THAT GROWING DATA THAT THE RISK
TO CHILDREN IS VERY LOW AND
WHILE MORE AND MORE ADULTS,
YOUNG ADULTS AND ADOLESCENTS
CONTINUE TO GET VAS COULD YOU
LATED AND PERCENT OF POSITIVITY
OF TESTS HAVE HIT AN ALL-TIME
LOW OF 2.7%.
IT’S TIME TO ALLOW OUR CHILDREN
TO GET BACK TO THAT NORMAL OF
NORMAL LIFE KNOWING THEY ARE NOT
A RISK TO SOCIETY AND RISK TO
COVID-19 FOR THEM IS NEGLIGIBLE.
AINSLEY: THAT’S THE PROBLEM WITH
THE STUDIES THEY INFLATE THE
NUMBERS AND EXPERTS MAKE
DECISIONS BASED ON THOSE
NUMBERS.
WE FIND OUT MONTHS LATER OR A
YEAR LATER NOT ALL OF THAT WAS
NECESSARILY TRUE.
MOST OF THOSE KIDS THAT WERE
STILL TESTING POSITIVE BUT DID
NOT HAVE ANY STOOMS SYMPTOMS WER
THE HOSPITAL FOR SURGERY,
PSYCHIATRIC ISSUES.